my audience knows if you've been
following the show for some time that I
avoid being overly optimistic or
pessimistic about any particular
election and I always make clear that no
matter what the polls tell us today the
only thing we can control is whether we
vote and we should always vote in that
context in the last week there are a
bunch of races that are going very much
the wrong direction there is what I
think can accurately be called a
democratic collapse happening in many
races and a possible Red Wave Rising now
at the start of the week I told you
zooming out the forecasts for the House
and Senate have worsened for Democrats
and they have improved for Republicans
but where can we see this at the
individual race level
and I'm going to tell you up front that
it these are this is ugly these are very
ugly numbers that I'm about to show you
here look at some of these races Florida
Senate incumbent Marco Rubio is
challenged by Val demings demings is a
great candidate who had one of the best
debate performances of all the debates
that we covered what at one point was a
Rubio lead in the region of five two
three four five six has now become a
seven and a half point lead for Marco
Rubio very quickly Getting Out Of Reach
for Val demings moving on to DeSantis
versus Charlie Crist also in Florida
Charlie Crist mopping the floor with
DeSantis who visibly malfunctioned on
Monday night we played the clips we
showed you all of it what at one point
was a five six seven point lead for
DeSantis has now swelled
uh to an 11 point average lead for
DeSantis with as much as a 14-point lead
in some of these individual polls this
is quickly Getting Out Of Reach Florida
quickly looking like it will fall to the
most extreme elements of the Republican
Party
or stay in their hands I think better
said in Georgia again talking about the
best Democratic performances this cycle
Stacey Abrams was one of them facing off
against incumbent Republican Governor
Brian Kemp what had been as you can see
if we go back actually I don't oh I do
have the older data what had been many
polls in the Kemp plus two four two five
one area
has now become Kemp 6 Plus 6.7 and
almost seven point lead for Brian Kemp
not totally Out Of Reach but
increasingly difficult for Democratic
Challenger Stacey Abrams I don't tell
you this to demoralize you know there's
this horrible thing that happens where
no matter what I say about polling
someone's mad if I say look the polls
are looking terrible for Democrats
people say oh David you're demoralizing
Democrats so they won't go vote
and if I say oh look the polls are
looking good for Democrats people write
to me they say David you're giving
people false confidence they're going to
think they don't need to vote folks I
tell you what is going on and I also
tell you how I believe we should react
and no matter what the polls say we
should react by voting but more of these
races here is a race where the Democrat
is still winning but by a dramatically
smaller margin than it was at one point
Dixon versus Whitmer Gretchen Whitmer is
the current Democratic governor of
Michigan Tudor Dixon is the Republican
Maga Challenger if you look you see that
even as late as August 24th Whitmer was
up by 16 points by the middle of
September that was down to an
eight-point lead the lead was halved
and now it is a three-point lead for the
Democrat Gretchen Whitmer Michigan
governorship is now in play for
Republicans it's sickening if you look
at Ohio Vance versus Ryan Tim Ryan the
Democratic Challenger not Challenger the
Democratic candidate JD Vance the
Republican candidate JD Vance by sucking
up ferociously to Donald Trump he was
able to secure an endorsement from
Donald Trump if you look at that race
what at one point uh
was a actually this this one actually
hasn't changed that much it's a relevant
one to include because it's important
but it actually has not changed that
much advances plus two and that's more
or less where it has been more or less
where it has been
um but it is
um potentially another seat that will
fall to Republicans
um Georgia Senate Walker versus Warnock
Rafael warnock's lead is now half a
point and this one is really really
sickening Herschel Walker can barely
speak and he can't explain his positions
on any issue he's completely incoherent
Warnock not a great debate performance
but clearly the competent candidate if
you look back at the history here
Warnock was up four to five points in
Late July still up four to five points
in August but that lead started to
shrink shrink shrink to the point of a
tie
briefly during the Walker Scandal
Warnock opened up a five-point lead it's
basically a tie Herschel Walker who
cannot speak and cannot think may
replace Raphael Warnock as a senator
from Georgia and then Texas governor
Greg Abbott the incumbent versus Beto
O'Rourke this at one point was a sort of
closer race if you look at late June it
was Abbott plus six if you look at
um there was a sort of brief point where
the liege was smaller I don't remember
exactly where it was oh it was it was
actually last year it was five this has
now become of more than eight point lead
for the incumbent Greg Abbott which in
Texas will be quite difficult for a
Democrat to overcome doesn't mean we
stay home
what else do you have to do on that day
we should all vote and we should fight
every race but there is a serious
concern right now that a red wave is
coming and it's a combination of a few
things most importantly most importantly
this is
the effect of Roe v Wade being
overturned which help Democrats
fading too soon being supplanted by
economic concerns and despite
essentially Full Employment and almost
unanimously positive economic indicators
rhetoric on inflation
reigning Supreme in the minds of many
voters and it is shaping up to be
potentially disastrous for Democrats so
what do we do we vote we vote we vote we
vote